et pour ne pas couper dans les
services pour Montréal.
Ce sixième budget
de l'administration Plante
atteint un nouveau record.
6,7 millards $, c'est 30 %
de plus qu'en 2017.
Et il contient la hausse de
taxes la plus significative
depuis 11 ans.
Plus 4,1 % en moyenne pour
le résidentiel, 2,9 % pour les
commerces et les industries.
La cause principale,
l'inflation.
VALÉRIE PLANTE
mairesse de Montréal
- Ça coûte extrêmement cher
à la Ville de Montréal, puis
nous, on reçoit pas de chèque
par la poste, là. Fait que,
il faut qu'on continue à offrir
les services aux Montréalais
parce que c'est ce à quoi
ils s'attendent.
- Mais tous les arrondissements
ne sont paauauaux devant
la hausse des impôts.
Parmi les plus modérées,
il y a Ville-Marie, Montréal-
Nord ou encore Verdun.
Ma r r r résidents de l'ile
Bizard, Hochelaga ou Côte-des-
Neiges verront grimper
leurs comptes de plus de 5 %.
- Alors que l'hypothèque,
elle, elle ne s'arrête pas,
il faut la payer chaque mois.
- C'est sûr qu'ils vont refiler
le prix, donc, aux locataires.
En même temps, t'as tout le
reste qui augmente, fait que là,
les gens ont plus de misère
à se loger, plus de misère
à se nourrir.
- L'opposition se dit jalouse
de la ville de Québec,
où la hausse de taxes a été
contenue à 2, 5 %.
AREF SALEM, chef de l'opposition
officielle Ville de Montréal
- Pourquoi la Ville de Montréal
ne peut pas serrer les dépenses?
Quand on parle : "on est en
train de serrer les dépenses"
et on embauche 646 nouvelles
personnes à la Ville,
il y a un problème.
DOMINIQUE OLLIVIER, présidente
comité exécutif Ville de Mtl
- Oui, on ajoute légèrement des
gens, mais on les ajoute dans
des choses concrètes, au service
des citoyens et pour pouvoir
avoir des économies plus tard.
- Au chapitre des dépenses,
100 millions de dollars
seront consacrés à la sécurité
publique pour embaucher
notamment 123 policiers.
Parmi les nouveaux revenus,
grâce aux compteurs d'eau,
Montréal va commencer l'année
prochaine à taxer les grands
consommateurs, les entreprises
qui utilisent plus de mille
mètres cube par an.
Mais au-delà des taxes, il y a
aumememememesures pour soulager
certains portefeuilles.
Celui des plus de 65 ans par
exemple, pour qui bus et métros
seront gratuits à partir
du 1er juillet.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréa